Mark fergus's penguin and Parker is the
production company that's going to be
making new Stargate
but how did we get to this point welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so to explain how we got to this point
where penguin and Parker is going to be
the production company for a new
Stargate franchise not just TV show
franchise
we have to go back about nine months so
even before the sale of Amazon was
finalized they were talking to Brad
Wright about the new Stargate and his
script that he'd written and now Amazon
even then felt that what MGM were trying
to produce with Stargate was just not
ambitious enough it wasn't big enough
but I am actually now being told that
Amazon never intended to go with Brad
right script they never liked it because
they thought it should be bigger but
actually they always intended to
hopefully find a different production
company somebody with the experience of
doing larger franchises including movies
to produce the series
they never felt that Brad Wright could
handle showrunning a project that would
become as big as they hope Stargate
would they have always said that they
felt that Stargate was the sleeping
giant of sci-fi and I'm being told that
there's been lots of meetings with Jenny
sulk and Michael Wright um with MGM and
Amazon other Executives and that they
have been comparing and looking at
things like Star Trek numbers to try to
figure out where they think Stargate
would go Michael Wright himself has
always been pushing for a Stargate
return and he's always felt according to
sources that it's never been utilized
well and that should have never been off
our screens as long as it has been we
also now know that there were certain
voices within MGM namely Michael Burnett
there was actually very much against
Stargate and was blocking it at the
boardroom level and he has now gone
don't forget to like subscribe and share
the video with all of your other Gator
friends also you go to side ashtrak.com
for brilliant Stargate related merged
just like this you can even buy socks
and anything else you want please also
don't forget the Sidetrack sides Channel
all the links are in the description
so then when the sale of mgm2 Amazon
went through Amazon had to restructure a
lot of their business but they also had
to review all of the different projects
that MGM were planning and Stargate was
one of those big projects that they had
to review they looked at what they were
going to do and they hated it apparently
but also the main thing was that they
really felt that this is a big franchise
this would be their Star Trek or their
Star Wars but this is something that if
they handled right could become equally
as big as any of those other franchises
maybe not Star Wars but definitely Star
Trek so they put the call out and
companies started to pitch their ideas
now we know for a fact that Bad Robot JJ
Abrams did do a pitch now I've heard
since actually that pitch didn't go very
well and kind of fell on deaf ears
I also know that there was a meeting
between Mark Fergus and MGM Executives
with an Amazon executive um involved and
they were actually asked following the
end of um the expanse if he would like
to get involved in another project and
if he did what project would that be and
he actually stated that he would love to
do something with Stargate so they went
away and they were allowed to also pitch
now I'm getting two versions of this
next bit so one version which is I've
been told quite a while ago that they
were asked then to produce a Content
Bible for the new franchise so it would
be a document that would tell them what
the Canon for this new series would be
what they were allowed to do and what
they weren't allowed to do now this
would be a document that whatever
production company then took on the
Stargate franchise would use they would
base all of the content on that and it
would tell them what they were allowed
to mess with and what they weren't
allowed to mess with
another version of the story is though
however that when Mark Fergus went away
and decided to do his pitch they did the
content Bible off their own backs and
this was one of the main reasons why
they then have been so successful in
their pitches because they didn't just
turn up with a pitch bundle and a story
idea they turned up with a whole
franchise idea they really apparently
went to town in the pitch meetings and
following meetings
they've also now done all sorts of
initial artwork CGI and all sorts to
show Amazon Executives exactly what they
want to do with the project
now either way this is pretty impressive
um on one hand either Amazon just
trusted them from the get-go and just
basically said look these are the guys
to develop this they did such a great
job with the expanse I imagine a lot of
the Amazon Executives knew exactly what
these guys are capable of so they just
said like we want you to develop this um
Bible for us crack on or Mark Fergus was
so excited by the idea of this project
that he went Way Beyond what other
companies did instead of just doing a
pitch and telling them a few ideas they
developed an entire universe
and that just blew Amazon Executives
away
now over the last few months there's
been certain negotiations but they've
also just happened to be waiting on
Amazon to make a final decision but also
Amazon have been restructuring a lot of
their Executives a restructuring that
seems to have now ended the only thing
they're really still Weighing on is that
MGM doesn't have an executive in charge
of movies and now that is going to be
important but I'll talk about that in
another video
but that is how we've got to where we
are Mark Fergus just came in and
absolutely destroyed the opposition
apparently and he has produced a project
that Amazon executive is incredibly
excited about but he is not just looking
at one series what I'm being told is is
they've created ideas for an entire
franchise and this could be an
absolutely massive project they are
looking at movies they are looking at
multiple TV series they really are
looking to do with Stargate what Disney
have done with Star Wars and I think
that is a pretty good comparison between
the two to be honest even though Star
Wars will always be the bigger franchise
I think it's the biggest franchise in in
sci-fi it just is
um I don't think we'll ever really get
their numbers but you know it's open but
I do think we can match Star Trek's
numbers particularly the way new Trek
has gone in the last few years
but the interesting thing with Star Wars
is that actually when Disney bought it
they had to re-jig some of the ideas and
they definitely then looked at Canon and
they made some big decisions on what
Canon was they swiped they wiped out
loads and loads of beta Cannon they
wiped out loads and loads of the novels
and things they just said look that's
not coming well that didn't happen would
go in a different direction they kept
much of what happened in the movies as
Canon but they moved forward with a
clear plan now I feel that's what Amazon
really have done with Stargate
particularly in the fact that they've
got the right person involved Mark
Fergus is a stickler for the detail
and he is very very good at keeping
those details straight if we want
somebody that is going to respect what
has come before have some decisions
about Canon Etc made very early on and
then stick to it and create storylines
that intertwine with each other while
being clever and make sense Mark
Ferguson his partner Hawk oatsby as most
definitely the people to do it so that's
how we've got to where we are guys
please get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think were you a fan of
the expanse are you excited by this news
are you as excited as me and hopeful the
negotiations go well and that we do get
an announcement in the new year is
something I've been told for quite a
while if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you want to support the channel and
become a fully fledged side tracker hit
the join button and as always please
stay safe Gators is coming home I'll see
you next time
[Music]